bon on commence dans l'orientation qu'on
veut pas forcément tous face à nîmes
commencez d'abord par trouver les
marches avec les changements
d'orientation avant de vous occuper des
objets et des chefs d'accord tu mérites
ou poésie et vous partez à votre avec de
chacun et on a les bras le long du corps
mais immédiat voilà c'est ludique assez
saccadée donc servez vous en pour les
hommes et les changements d'orientation
et l'articulation basse il faut
quelqu'un décide ça peut-être d'abord
qu'est ce
[Musique]
c'est un exercice qui est spécifiquement
fait pour vous apprendra comment est ce
qu on décompose donc j'avais donné un
exemple en montrant où je peux le
refaire
quand je veux dans la vie quotidienne je
vois un objet je fais ça dans le théâtre
qu'on pratique nous je vois un objet je
fais ce que tu vois la différence et ça
j'ai repensé à dosettes à tête voilà et
sasso effaça retombe et voilà et tout
d'un coup ils the pack mais non que le
crayon
souviens-toi éclaté en 2000
ok pas mal qui reste un constat ne bouge
pas
tu retires tu te lèves atteignant deux
fois
une fois là ça c'est juste à partir mais
[Musique]
jusqu'où notre soyez comme ça qu'elle
prenne un peu le large c'est bien parce
qu il ya des changements d'orientation
vous avez oublié un truc ah ben c'est
dommage de ne pas l'avoir à l'oreille tu
es bien vie est parfaite au premier et
puis on enchaîne tu fais tout en même
temps pied au sol tam harcelé et c'est
parce que ça te tires de cheval sa tenue
et pour toujours décompose loisirs fait
pas sega pass bien sûr comme un monde se
méfie toi voilà elle dort je le touche
d'après se relève après leur souriait à
la brayelle peur sur mineurs et ainsi de
suite
et voilà après une étape mais d'abord
puis à l'est le temps de départ de l'un
composé nous avons chacune
ce que vous pouvez répéter précisément
et à partir de ça non mais vous voyez le
courage et vous échanger les mains sur
la deuxième fois fermé d'abord ça va me
tuer laurent gbagbo dont il a tous les
deux à damas qui prend le relais ils
font comme fait parce que c'est un des
moments pour le faire l'objet est
peut-être pas tous les objets en même
temps parce que comme vous a dit les
objets tous les objets
c'est violent vous allez changer vous
mettre dans vos tenues
normal à l'aise moi je reste comme ça
c'est bien si vous voulez prendre
quelques minutes pour voir